ahora
[Música]
usualmente los intereses son algo que
nos encanta ver y descubrir y es algo
que lo personal disfruto mucho y me
gusta mucho hablar de ellos como ya lo
he hecho en otras ocasiones pero así
como de ocasiones en donde los secretos
de algún juego son descubiertos con gran
facilidad o los creadores de dicho
secreto lo dejan oculto a simple vista
para que nosotros lo descubramos con
bastante rapidez pues demonios también
hay ocasiones en las que los
desarrolladores de ciertos juegos se les
va la cabeza y deciden que si queremos
ver algún secreto tendremos que volver
los detectives profesionales
ya que en ocasiones es realmente
sorprendente la cantidad de esfuerzo que
pueden ponerle estos secretos con muchos
enigmas y acertijos por solucionar antes
de poder acceder a ellos pero más
sorprendente aún es saber que algunas
personas estuvieron lo suficientemente
locas como para intentarlo y de hecho
haber podido solucionarlo así que hoy
vamos a ver una lista de los sister ex y
secretos más difíciles y elaborados
encontrados en videojuegos
[Música]
para el field al igual que call of duty
toma la costumbre de esconder secretos
cada vez más y más complicados en sus
juegos por si te aburrirás de darle
tiros a cualquier cosa que se mueva pues
podrías poner te investigar un poco los
mapas mientras los otros jugadores se
matan entre ellos
y belleville 4 tienen los secretos más
infames de la saga sino tan
innecesariamente complicado que fue
apodado como el easter illuminati todo
el proceso es realmente largo y tiene un
montón de pasos así que resumir un poco
el proceso pero es algo más o menos así
en el mapa dragon ball y tendrás que
encontrar siete interruptores muy muy
pequeños que están muy bien escondidos
cada uno de estos interruptores enciende
algunas luces de esta zona así que luego
de encontrarlos tendrás que presionarlos
en un orden específico hasta que todas
las luces de dicha zona estén encendidas
al hacer esto desbloqueará es un teclado
oculto el cual interactúas con él
causarás a su vez una linterna comienza
a transmitir un mensaje en código morse
que por supuesto tienes que traducir y
descifrar así que es conmigo bien porque
aún no acaba este mensaje en código
morse te enviará hacia otro mapa en lo
que tienes que pararte en un lugar
específico en donde se reproducirá un
clip de audio distorsionado que si lo
reproduce es más rápido con algún
programa de edición te dará un mensaje
que luego tendrás que codificar al
multiplicar ciertas letras de dicho
mensaje usando caracteres numéricos esto
te dará como resultado un código que
puedes introducir en el teclado que ya
vimos antes luego introducir dicho
código otro mensaje con código morse
sera
que ya habiendo sido descifrado te hará
un último código que tendrás que
introducir con otro teclado oculto en
otro mapa el resto sencillo y que ganas
al final de todo estar tu trabajo una
esquina si decidir si esto vale la pena
o no eso te lo dejo a ti
pero las risas no faltaron
controles al juego bastante único que
definitivamente te recomiendo es un gran
juego con perspectiva y jugabilidad
interesantes en el juego poco
convencional
y si no tal clase de juego era obvio que
sus secretos no iban a ser tan sencillos
de revelar dentro de la banda sonora de
este título se encuentra una canción
llamada take control que obras varias
veces mientras avanzas en el juego pero
pocos notaron que había un mensaje
secreto dentro de esta canción pues
escuchamos con atención oír a sonidos
que no pertenecen a la melodía sonidos
que si reproduces al revés está
arrojaron un mensaje que dice lo
siguiente
[Música]
por qué
[Aplausos]
[Música]
no
de acuerdo eso está muy bien pero qué
[ __ ] significa todo esto para aumento
que este mensaje fue descubierto nada
cosa que dejó a los jugadores ansiosos
ya que estaban seguros que si no había
nada en el juego base seguramente
encontraría nadal con el dlc que saldría
dentro de poco igual a ya que tenían
razón tomando en cuenta el mensaje que
viste antes y un poco de suerte
descubrió que en esta ubicación
específica habrá una pared que podrá
romper y acceder a una zona secreta
explorando la profundamente encontrarás
una habitación con una radio que
nuevamente reproducirá la canción take
on show con el mensaje secreto si te
toman la molestia explorar esta pequeña
habitación encontrarás que hay otra
pared que puedes romper detrás de esta
pared hay una gran habitación en donde
lo único que encontrarás será este reloj
en el cual se introduce el código del
mensaje que te muestra el inicio abrirás
un camino hacia un lugar donde tendrá
escalar tres veces esta cuerda con lo
cual te transportará finalmente a esta
zona en donde al final encontrarás tu
premio una llave que al recogerla te
harán mover oikos y el efecto de
recuperar salud cada vez que evade es
habilidad que cree mente será de mucha
ayuda
[Música]
monsters ball and the cars kingdom es un
juego de aventura y puzzles que no llego
a ser muy conocido a pesar de ser
bastante bueno el juego te pone la piel
un joven llamado jean quien descubre que
su tío está usando magia para convertir
las personas del lugar en animales a lo
largo de su camino para tener a su tío
el malote chino quien la habilidad de
convertirse en distintos animales cada
uno con diferentes habilidades que lo
ayudarán en su aventura bien ahora la
razón por la que este historia que está
aquí es por dos motivos lo primero es
que el secreto como tal es
innecesariamente complicado segundo el
juego no te da ni siquiera una miserable
pista al menos en vales yo te hago en la
lamparita titilante o encontró la
cancioncita esa pero aquí
descúbrelo tú mismo cabrón en fin la
cosa va así en el centro de la aldea de
luque hay un pozo que está bloqueado y
no se abrirá por nada del mundo ni
siquiera cuando lleva a cabo hasta el
juego pero resulta que después de todo
si hay una manera de abrirlo para esto
primero tendrás que encontrar con ayuda
de las habilidades del cuartito y los
demás animales cinco interruptores muy
bien escondidos esto hará que se revele
un mecanismo en una torre que tendrá que
ser girado en un orden específico hecho
esto finalmente abrirás una entrada
hacia el pozo pero no
y ya que dentro del pozo estará otro
acertijo aquí abajo encontrarás 5
antorchas que tendrán que ser encendidas
si nuevamente en un orden específico y
siguiendo ciertos pasos de los cuales
para aclarar otra vez nunca se dio pista
alguna así que ya te imaginarás cuánto
tiempo tardaron en descifrar todo esto
después de todos estos pasos por fin se
abrirá la puerta que te llevará a una
habitación con un par de consolas con
las que puedes interactuar para jugar
una versión de 8 bits de monster ball
o aquí buenos los gráficos [ __ ] qué
buenos que buenos dios qué buenos los
gráficos
calidad 4k
[Música]
de van dyck es un juego raro como el
solo y siendo así los secretos que
esconde no podrían ser igualmente
ridículamente extraños y complicados
pues el creador decidió que quería
divertirse un poco con los jugadores y
los iba a poner a trabajar pues en la
expansión after bird escondieron un
secreto tan extraño y tan grande que ni
siquiera cupo completamente en el juego
todo comienza en el modo de juego creed
que es como tipo de modo horda pero con
estas bolitas en este modo de juego
tenemos una máquina de donaciones en la
cual a medida que depositamos monedas
conseguiremos objetos y mejoras para
nuestro personaje lo interesante es que
si donamos 999 monedas en esta máquina
obtendremos este inusual logro esta
imagen oculta un código que al ser
solucionado nos llevará a una página
donde encontraremos esta imagen dentro
de la cual habrá un pasaje de génesis
30-35 después de que se encontrara esta
imagen los fanáticos estaban estancados
y no sabían qué más hacer hasta que uno
de ellos se dio cuenta de que el creador
del juego estaba no pista acerca de este
secreto en su cuenta de twitter a través
de tweets con mensajes ocultos con ayuda
de estos tweets se dieron cuenta de que
para seguir el misterio tenían que ir a
la pasarela de santacruz una atracción
ubicada en eeuu al llegar a dicho lugar
encontraron este para nada perturbado
cartel de se usa con un número de
teléfono incompleto
posteriormente usando datos escondidos
en el juego y algunas de las pistas ya
antes solucionadas se logró completar el
número de teléfono el llamar sonado
mensaje pregrabado que horas después fue
reemplazado por otro mensaje que dice lo
siguiente
jones y jon kyl
muy bien
cada
nuevamente con ayuda de las pistas que
el creador del juego les dieron cuenta
de que este mensaje en realidad es un
mensaje que tenían que descifrar ahora
con el mensaje ya descifrado obtuvieron
otra ubicación al cual tendrían que
existir esta vez un edificio en donde
encontrarían un montón de cosas pero más
importante cavando un poco bajo tierra
hallarían este extraño muñeco con varios
mensajes escritos en su cuerpo los
cuales los guiarán a una cuenta de
twitter cuenta a la cual con los
mensajes escritos en el cuerpo del
muñeco cientos de personas pudieron
acceder y tuitear lo que quisieran así
dándole una voz al muñeco finalmente
unos días después los creadores de todo
este caos por medio de la misma cuenta
de twitter publicaron una imagen de un
logro desbloqueado que dice la comunidad
desbloqueo algo oculto obteniendo así el
personaje culto the keeper siendo ese el
final de uno de los histéricos más
elaborados y complicados que ha habido
hasta la fecha bien hecho hasta acá
este es probablemente el histérico más
grande de todos los tiempos y créeme no
estoy exagerando de hecho tengo planeado
dedicarle algún día a un vídeo entero a
este tema que me parece supremamente
interesante así que hoy voy a saltarme
muchos de los pasos y resumir un montón
todo el este como tal de otra manera el
vídeo se alargaría una eternidad guayas
es una serie de videojuegos conocida por
su gran dedicación a la hora de crear y
esther ex muy elaborado pero esta vez se
mamá y es que no veremos el final de
este secreto sino hasta el año 2000 113
no lo digo en serio como dije antes los
jugadores de actuarios ya estaban
acostumbrados a solucionar toda clase de
secretos pero nada los iba a preparar
para que encontrarían en twilight
filtran todo comienza con la quinta
llave un logro que conseguiremos en el
juego al encontrar una llave escondida
en el editor de mapas no olvides esto
más adelante verás porque ahora en el
juego hay distintas piezas de madera con
letras talladas que están repartidas por
todos sus mapas lo cual despertó la
curiosidad de los jugadores así que
reunieron todas las letras repartidas a
lo largo de todo el juego y formaron
algo así y esto qué significa ni [ __ ]
idea pero afortunadamente
orden enorme cerebro descubrió que en
realidad esto es un código el con ayuda
de la comunidad logró descifrarlo como
resultado obtuvieron el siguiente
mensaje
este mensaje resultó contener
instrucciones pues les pedí a los
jugadores que el mapa nation
usando la moto escorpión pusieran la
música del juego en cero y se ubicarán
en un lugar específico e introdujeron la
clave si hacían esto correctamente se
reproduciría el siguiente mensaje
así no es
siendo padre
yo vi
[Música]
pipita
con el decoro
más días
la sierra
[Música]
eso es hoy
hace una hermosa canción pero qué [ __ ]
significa bueno como es la canción los
secretos están escondidos en los tonos
más brillantes así que tomando el
espectro de la canción que acabas de oír
extrayendo los tonos más brillantes
encontrar un código morse exclusivo a
una página web con una imagen que tenían
que alterar usando distintos filtros lo
que a su vez reveló un poema en latín
pero todo esto fue removido al cabo de
un par de días y todo el contenido en la
página web fue reemplazado por este
conjunto de imágenes que fueron
desveladas una por una durante 21 días
nuevamente esto significaba un nuevo
mensaje oculto que descifrar y desde
luego que lo hicieron una vez resuelto
esto la página cambió totalmente para
mostrar únicamente esto en esta nueva
página se ha encontrado las coordenadas
de lugares en todo el mundo en donde se
encontraron cuatro cajas que contenían
una llave y una placa que decía mediodía
de 2.113 en el primer sábado de agosto
una de las cinco llaves abriera la caja
debajo de la torre eiffel
pero si sólo se encontraron cuatro cajas
donde está la quinta llave bueno esa es
la llave de la que te hablé al principio
la llave escondida dentro del juego es
la quinta llave mediante impresora 3d
puede ser creada así que si todos estos
misterios secretos códigos y acertijos
con los más grandes secretos de los
videojuegos todo eso vino de un juego de
motos
una locura no nadie sabe que tendrás la
caja sólo se sabe que en el año 2000 113
debajo de la torre eiffel esa caja se
abrirá
[Música]
vaya pues diablos increíble saber que
existen este tipo de secretos e
intereses parece bastante interesante y
genial que les dediquen tanto tiempo
entre esas cosas como estas tanto los
que crean los secretos como los que
están lo suficientemente locos como para
solucionarlos quién sabe tal vez el día
de mañana conozcamos más secretos como
estos
ya veremos hasta la próxima
[Música]